Trascrizione: Laura Fumagalli
Revisore: Sofia Ramundo
(Applausi)
Dall'inizio del gennaio del 2001
lavoro come genetista
all'università di Modena e Reggio Emilia.
E in questi 18 anni ho avuto modo
di vivere
quella che probabilmente
è una delle fasi più emozionanti
della storia della genetica
e molto probabilmente anche dell'intera
storia della scienza e della vita.
Perché nel corso
di questi ultimi vent'anni
abbiamo imparato a leggere
con un'enorme facilità
tutte quelle informazioni che sono scritte
dentro il DNA di qualsiasi organismo.
Sia un microrganismo,
una pianta, un animale.
Siamo in grado di leggere tutte
le informazioni che ci sono nel DNA
e di aggiungere informazioni.
Questo viaggio comincia nel 2001.
Comincia nel 2001 con il sequenziamento
del Progetto genoma umano.
Cioè nel 2001, per la prima volta,
riusciamo ad avere
le informazioni su tutto quello
che le nostre cellule possono fare
e perché lo possono fare.
Tutti i nostri geni a questo punto
hanno una sequenza
e noi possiamo dire che cosa fanno.
Chiudere il Progetto genoma
è stato considerato
una sfida estremamente importante
da un punto di vista culturale
e da un punto di vista tecnologico.
Perché per complessità,
secondo alcuni storici della scienza,
sequenziare il Progetto genoma umano
era secondo in una classifica ideale
solo dopo le missioni Apollo che
hanno portato l'uomo sulla Luna.
Un progetto complicato perché
è un progetto che
è costato 3 miliardi di dollari,
ha visto lavorare assieme
più di mille ricercatori
provenienti un po' da tutto il mondo,
ed è un progetto che è durato
soli 13 anni.
Si stimava ne durasse 15,
in realtà, in soli 13 anni,
sono riusciti ad avere che cosa?
La sequenza completa dei nostri geni.
Ed è stata una scoperta importantissima.
Ancora oggi il genoma umano
viene considerato
il patrimonio dell'umanità.
E avere il Progetto genoma umano
ha chiaramente creato tante aspettative
perché a questo punto potremmo chiederci
ciascuno di noi che cos'ha
nel proprio DNA.
Posso leggere nel vostro genoma,
il vostro destino,
quali malattie avrete,
quali alimenti o farmaci potete usare
o quali dovete evitare.
E questo è quello che hanno cominciato
a chiedersi anche i genetisti.
È chiaro che se io vi dicessi
"devo fare un nuovo Progetto genoma,
mi servono altri 13 anni
e 3 miliardi di dollari",
immagino che non sarete
immediatamente disponibili
a fare una donazione
alla fine di questa conferenza.
In realtà cosa è successo?
Che i genetisti hanno cominciato a dire:
"Se noi avessimo la capacità
di sequenziare DNA
in modo veloce, economico e processivo,
potremmo dire a ciascuna persona
cos'ha nel proprio DNA."
E quindi cos'è stato richiesto?
Speriamo ci sia un'evoluzione
scientifica, un'evoluzione tecnologica,
e questo è esattamente
quello che c'è stato.
Quello che è successo nel corso,
in particolare, degli ultimi 10 anni
è che le metodiche di sequenziamento
sono diventate sempre più veloci,
sono diventate sempre più processive,
sono diventate sempre più economiche.
Che cosa vuol dire?
10 anni fa, io ero in grado di sequenziare
un tratto di DNA nel mio laboratorio
impiegando circa 2 ore
per sequenziare 1000 nucleotidi,
cioè per capire in che ordine erano
i nucleotidi,
che sono le lettere,
i componenti di base del DNA.
Quindi 2 ore, 1000 nucleotidi,
spendendo circa 10 dollari, 10 euro.
Oggi che cosa posso fare
nel mio laboratorio?
In un paio di ore, posso sequenziare
una gigabase di DNA,
cioè un miliardo di nucleotidi.
E se io dicessi:
"Voglio sequenziare il genoma,
il mio genoma", oggi lo potrei fare
con meno di 1000 euro.
Quindi l'evoluzione tecnologica
è stata enorme.
E questo ha avuto tante conseguenze.
Perché?
Perché a questo punto ciascuno di voi
potrebbe farsi il proprio genoma.
È chiaro che è un esperimento
un po' costosetto,
però poteste andare a vedere
cosa c'è nel vostro genoma.
E non solo.
Perché a questo punto fare
il Progetto genoma cosa ha significato?
Sviluppare strumenti estremamente
veloci ed efficaci per sequenziare DNA.
Ha voluto dire
sviluppare delle banche dati
in cui accumulare tutti questi dati.
Perché se il Progetto genoma umano
è un patrimonio dell'umanità
tutti questi dati devono essere pubblici.
In più questi dati
io li devo poter analizzare.
E quindi c'è stato
uno sviluppo informatico.
È nata la bio informatica.
A questo punto però che cosa è successo?
Che chi, come me, lavora
con insetti e batteri di interesse agrario
ha avuto la possibilità
di poter fare il genoma
dell'animale, della pianta
o del microrganismo con cui lavora.
Cioè che cosa significa?
Che il Progetto genoma umano
è stato il volano
per una vera e propria rivoluzione
che ha avuto un effetto su chiunque lavori
con qualsiasi organismo.
Quelli che avete visto adesso comparire
sono quelli che io chiamo
i "genomi da copertina",
cioè sono i genomi delle specie più note.
Però a questo punto, l'idea è:
voi potete prendere qualsiasi organismo
e avere il suo genoma.
Io ho lavorato ultimamente
con un batterio
di cui non si sapeva niente.
Mi hanno dato un batterio
e mi hanno detto:
"Ma questo batterio cosa fa?"
È chiaro che voi non potete guardarlo
e dire cosa farà.
Abbiamo preso il suo DNA.
Due settimane dopo avevamo
il suo Progetto genoma
completamente sequenziato.
Sappiamo esattamente
che cosa fa quel batterio
senza aver fatto
nessun esperimento.
Questo lo potete fare con le piante.
Lo potete fare con un animale.
E lo potete fare quindi per affrontare
per qualsiasi tematica
sia per voi interessante.
Una delle applicazioni
che io trovo più interessanti
che possiamo oggi sviluppare è affrontare
lo studio della domesticazione.
La domesticazione
è quel processo fantastico
per cui i nostri antenati
sono riusciti a domesticare,
quindi passare da piante selvatiche
a varietà domesticate.
La domesticazione
è quel processo meraviglioso
per i cui i nostri antenati
sono passati dal teosinte,
che è quella piccola spighetta
che vedete sulla sinistra
ai mais moderni.
La domesticazione è quindi
un processo incredibile
perché studiando la domesticazione
noi possiamo studiare
la storia della nostra civiltà.
Ed è chiaro che già solo
questa prima immagine
vi spiega la potenza della domesticazione.
Se io vi dicessi: "Vi invito a cena e
vi offro una bella spiga di terosinte,
e potete anche fare il bis".
Non sono convinto che molti di voi
tornerebbero a cena a casa mia.
Al contrario se io vi offrissi
una bella pannocchia di mais...
Io questo processo lo posso studiare
oggi a livello genetico.
Possiamo avere il genoma
della specie selvatica.
delle varietà oggi coltivate.
Possiamo andare a vedere
che cosa è accaduto.
E questo diventa ancora più evidente
se andiamo a prendere questa piantina.
Questa brassicoleracea è
una piantina abbastanza insignificante,
ha dei fiorellini giallini molto carini.
Però da questa pianta insignificante
la domesticazione ha portato alla comparsa
del cavolo, del broccolo e del cavolfiore.
Cioè quando voi mangiate il cavolo,
il broccolo o un cavolfiore
state mangiando un mutante.
Non spaventatevi,
non è nulla di pericoloso.
State mangiando una pianta
che ha avuto una mutazione
per cui da quella piantina
che vedete al centro
sono derivate le varietà domesticate.
Come hanno fatto
a ottenere questo risultato
i nostri antenati?
Non lo sappiamo,
stiamo parlando di qualcosa
che è successo 10,12 mila anni fa.
Studiare il genoma ci permette
di capire
che cosa hanno fatto i nostri antenati.
Questo diventa importante perché
quando i nostri antenati
hanno fatto la domesticazione
ovviamente non conoscevano la genetica,
non avevano strumenti molecolari
per vedere che cosa stavano facendo.
E quindi hanno ottenuto solo
alcune delle possibili,
potenziali forme domesticate
che una pianta selvatica ci poteva dare.
E quindi cosa possiamo fare oggi?
Prendiamo tutte queste varietà,
possiamo avere il loro genoma,
e possiamo andare a vedere
quali sono le mutazioni alla base
di quelle caratteristiche
per cui queste varietà ci piacciono.
Ma una volta che abbiamo questo dato
possiamo fare una cosa bellissima.
Possiamo pensare di ripetere
la domesticazione.
Cioè possiamo pensare
di ripartire dalle piante selvatiche
e ridomesticarle per creare qualcosa
che rispecchi le necessità attuali.
Il processo di domesticazione è,
abbiamo detto,
avvenuto tra i 10/12 mila anni fa,
quando il clima sulla Terra
era ben diverso da quello attuale,
sia per regime di temperature
che per piovosità.
Quindi le piante che noi abbiamo adesso
non sono quelle varietà che probabilmente
saranno molto produttive
nel prossimo futuro.
Perché quindi non ripetere
la domesticazione?
Chi di voi si interessa
di biologia evoluzionistica
conoscerà sicuramente Stephen Jay Gould,
un gigante dell'evoluzione.
Stephen Jay Gould ci dice:
"Guardate che se voi prendete
il film della storia della vita,
lo rimandate indietro,
lo riavvolgete e lo fate ripartire,
non otterrete mai due volte
lo stesso risultato,
perché l'evoluzione si basa
su mutazioni casuali."
Questo è verissimo,
ma se lavoriamo con le selezioni naturali.
Noi oggi in genetica possiamo lavorare
con la selezione artificiale.
Possiamo essere noi che,
generazione dopo generazione,
in laboratorio controlliamo quello
che si sta formando.
Non vi sto dicendo:
"Andiamo in un campo e aspettiamo che
compaiano le mutazioni
per dare qualcosa che ci interessa".
Sappiamo quali sono le mutazioni
che dobbiamo avere,
siamo noi che andiamo a mettere laddove
vogliamo averle
per produrre quello che ci serve
per garantire le produzioni alimentari
nel prossimo futuro.
E a questo punto
possiamo essere noi a decidere
che caratteristiche queste piante
devono avere.
Voi capite che cominciamo a cambiare
un po' il modo in cui viviamo
i viventi che ci circondano.
Perché a questo punto possiamo pensare
di influenzare la forma dei viventi.
Ma aggiungiamo un altro elemento.
Noi abbiamo a disposizione un enorme
patrimonio di piante
che vengono identificate
come semi domesticate.
Sono piante per cui è cominciato
il processo di domesticazione,
ma poi, per cause contingenti,
questo processo non si è completato.
Ma noi sappiamo quali sono
le caratteristiche
che le piante domesticate devono avere.
Ad esempio, tutte le volte che prendete
una pianta per seme, che cos'ha?
Il seme è diventato grande,
il seme rimane in una spiga,
i semi germinano simultaneamente,
hanno una dormienza ridotta,
la pianta che porta alla spiga
rimane eretta e non si sdraia.
Tutte queste sono caratteristiche
fenotipiche, direbbe un genetista,
cioè caratteristiche che potete osservare
ma di cui noi conosciamo i geni.
E la cosa che si è osservata
è che anche se le piante domesticate
sono molto diverse l'una dall'altra
da un punto di vista tassonomico,
molto spesso i geni che sono coinvolti
sono gli stessi.
E quindi che cosa succede?
Che noi oggi possiamo prendere
una pianta domesticata
e vedere che geni ha.
Possiamo prendere
una pianta semi domesticata
e completare nella domesticazione.
E questo potrà sembrarvi fantascientifico
ma è quello
che è stato fatto con la patata.
O meglio, con due cugine della patata.
Sono due piante che appartengono
allo stesso genere
ma non sono della stessa specie.
Che vantaggio c'è?
Ogni pianta si ammala perché
viene a contatto con patogeni e parassiti.
Piante di specie diverse
non sono ugualmente sensibili
agli stessi patogeni.
Alcuni gruppi di ricerca
hanno preso due specie
che sono simili alla patata
e hanno ottenuto un tubero
che è analogo a quello della patata
ma, essendo derivato da un'altra specie,
non ammala delle stesse malattie.
E quindi questo diventa interessante.
Perché vuole dire che partite
da una specie semi domesticata
e ne completate
il processo di domesticazione
come avete scelto voi in laboratorio.
Noi finora abbiamo sempre guardato
alla genetica
come una disciplina storica.
Cioè leggevamo nel DNA
la storia evolutiva di quella specie.
Noi questo lo possiamo ancora fare.
Ma se prima i geni ci servivano
per studiare le forme della natura,
noi oggi possiamo definire in laboratorio
che forma dovrà avere la natura
nel prossimo futuro.
Quindi non solo i geni per la forma
ma definire noi le forme.
Se prima eravamo
passeggeri dell'evoluzione
e vedevamo dove l'evoluzione
ci aveva portato,
dove aveva portato i nostri antenati
e le piante e gli animali
che vivono con noi,
a questo punto possiamo essere noi
coloro che guidano l'evoluzione.
E questo lo possiamo fare perché,
oltre a lavorare con il materiale genetico
che c'è già nelle piante,
possiamo pensare di aggiungere
informazione genetica.
E il mio consiglio è
segnatevi queste lettere.
CRISPR.
CRISPR è una metodica
estremamente interessante
perché grazie a questo strumento,
che tra l'altro è stato derivato
dalla ricerca di base,
perché è derivato dal modo
in cui i batteri eliminano
i virus che potrebbero ucciderli.
Utilizzando questa metodica,
voi potete prendere un gene qualsiasi
e inserirlo nel genoma
di un qualsiasi vivente,
decidendo dove
quel gene deve andare a collocarsi.
E quindi potete aggiungere delle funzioni.
Potete aggiungere solo un gene?
No, potete aggiungere addirittura
intere vie metaboliche.
Tutto questo è possibile
grazie a due brillantissime genetiste.
Si chiamano Jennifer Doudna
ed Emmanuelle Charpentier,
che per la prima volta hanno capito
che questo sistema
poteva avere delle applicazioni.
E su chi? Su chiunque DNA.
È chiaro che se io vi dico:
"Abbiamo un metodo
per modificare il genoma".
Cosa vuole dire?
Che qui voi potete scegliere un gene
e aggiungerlo.
Oppure potete prendere un gene
che ha una certa sequenza nucleotidica
e dire:
"Questa sequenza io la voglio cambiare,
la voglio correggere".
Pensate a una persona
che ha una malattia genetica,
andate a correggere la mutazione
che gli causa la malattia genetica.
Quindi immediatamente
quando si parla di CRISPR
viene in mente questo:
la possibilità di fare
l'editing dell'umanità.
Vorrei rassicurarvi,
la maggior parte degli scienziati
non vuole fare esseri umani
geneticamente modificati.
Ci sono alcuni ricercatori,
non italiani fortunatamente,
la cui attività andrebbe monitorata
proprio perché invece stanno
lavorando sull'uomo
e noi non siamo pronti né tecnicamente,
né da un punto di vista etico
per lavorare con l'uomo.
In realtà la maggior parte
degli scienziati
non vuole fare bambini
geneticamente modificati.
Vuole fare zucchine
geneticamente modificate.
Vuole fare piante
che possano essere coltivate
e che rispondano alle sfide che oggi
l'agricoltura si trova ad affrontare.
Perché? Perché immaginate
la globalizzazione
oggi è una globalizzazione
non solo delle merci,
è una globalizzazione dei patogeni,
è una globalizzazione dei parassiti,
e quindi gli agricoltori
si trovano a fronteggiare
ogni anno una nuova specie invasiva.
Piovosità.
I regimi di piovosità ormai
sono imprevedibili,
dobbiamo avere qualche cosa
per rispondere
e questo qualcosa sono
delle nuove varietà,
che non ci sono in natura
e che abbiamo la possibilità di costruire.
Quindi non immaginate che chi fa scienza,
genetica in questo modo,
voglia fare un bambino
geneticamente modificato.
Vogliamo fare delle piante
geneticamente migliorate.
Perché a questo punto
potremmo anche pensare
di prendere una pianta selvatica
domesticarla, migliorarla,
e rispondere a quelle che sono
le necessità attuali.
È chiaro che queste metodiche
hanno delle potenzialità enormi,
perché vi dicevo le possiamo applicare
a qualsiasi organismo.
Nel mio laboratorio ad esempio lavoriamo
con batteri e insetti di interesse agrario
e l'idea qual è?
Ad esempio un progetto che abbiamo
è quello di prendere dei batteri
e di modificarli geneticamente
in modo da poterli rimettere in suoli
in cui la biodiversità microbica
è stata fortemente compromessa,
e quindi il suolo è molto depauperato.
Oppure possiamo pensare
di prendere dei batteri,
ed è quello che stiamo già facendo,
e far sì che questi batteri producano
delle molecole che sono in grado
di stimolare la pianta
a utilizzare meglio i fertilizzanti.
E quindi possiamo usare
meno fertilizzanti.
Possiamo usare molecole
che stimolano la pianta
a produrre molecole difensive
e quindi possiamo usare
meno chimica in campo.
La genetica diventa oggi
una delle armi più potenti
che possiamo avere per vincere
la sfida della sostenibilità
e rendere l'agricoltura
sempre più sostenibile.
George Church, che è il genetista
americano che vedete qui in foto,
dice che noi stiamo vivendo
quella che si chiama una fase di rigenesi.
In che senso di rigenesi?
Nel senso che noi possiamo
ripetere l'atto della Genesi,
nel senso quell'atto creativo
che è descritto nel libro della Genesi.
Ora, capisco che citare
il libro della Genesi
parlando di genetica
può sembrare un po' blasfemo,
però a un grande genetista,
soprattutto a un genetista
che di cognome fa Church
possiamo anche concederlo.
Ma quello che lui vi dice è:
"Noi abbiamo delle enormi
possibilità tecniche
e abbiamo il dovere di sfruttarle".
Un altro grande genetista americano
che si chiama Craig Venter dice:
"Guardate che oggi l'unico limite
che la scienza ha
è l'immaginazione dei ricercatori".
Perché noi oggi abbiamo tutti
gli strumenti per costruire il futuro,
dobbiamo solo immaginare
che tipo di futuro vogliamo.
È chiaro che associate
a tutte queste possibilità
deve essere abbinato
il senso di responsabilità.
La responsabilità per cui
gli scienziati devono assicurarsi
che quello che fanno non sia pericoloso,
che quello che fanno
non sia dannoso per gli altri uomini,
per le altre specie animali e vegetali.
Ma è importante ricordare che
responsabilità vuole anche dire
assicurare che chi produce
quello che noi mangiamo
sia in grado di rispondere
alle sfide che arrivano oggi.
Responsabiltà vuole dire
dare il meglio dell'innovazione
a chi in campo lavora.
Tenete conto che molto spesso
noi abbiamo in mente
il concetto di tradizione.
In realtà ciò che noi chiamiamo tradizione
i nostri nonni chiamavano innovazione.
E la storia della domesticazione
è questo:
è una storia di innovazione.
L'evoluzione del nostro cibo
è passata attraverso l'evoluzione,
l'evoluzione del nostro cibo
passa dallo studio del suo DNA.
Grazie
(Applausi)